how much time do you have for me to tell  you the story of Black Swan I'd never  danced in my life  um I trained for four months for seven  days a week five hours a day including  one day of card an hour of cardio a day  um I had one day off on my birthday  I tore a ligament I dislocated my  shoulder I have two scars on my back and  it was worth every minute  I will never dance again I promise you I  will never put on that point shoe ever  again it was  the hardest thing I've ever done and I  tell you this because I am a strong  believer in mind over matter and I was  like well I wear heels I can do this I  was wrong Christian Louboutin is  uncomfortable this takes the case